many of my longtime viewers will know
that dead space is my de facto favorite
game of all time and has been since
2008. I've been essentially making
videos about it since I was nine years
old what the heck is that
okay I brought back your giant Satan
Rock can I go home now my uncle voiced
that I've even cosplayed Dead space's
main protagonist to Isaac Clark twice
over the years as my craft skills have
improved so as an adult with Arrested
Development I'm Overjoyed to revisit the
original game again in 4k with Isaac
finally allowed to verbally comment on
just how much fun he's having
and with great Arrested Development
comes a substantial addiction to
fortnite skins seeing Isaac lovingly
ported over to that game unlocked an
ancient memory deep in the recesses of
my mind where he was skateboarding and
golfing and a bunch of other funny stuff
so I did some research to try and find
out just how many games he's appeared in
and was astonished to realize that this
depressed loser with a high-tech
welder's mask has been everywhere
it's appeared in more video games than
Master Chief and even Kratos two of the
biggest characters in AAA franchise
gaming I don't know I guess I've become
something of an icon he's even been in
the same game as Kratos twice
just to get the full picture I went
searching to see if anyone's done a
video to compile how many crossovers
this character has been subject to and
realize no one else has done it yet so I
may as well be the first if it's an
excuse to talk about dead space on the
channel some more here is an extensive
list of every non-dead space appearance
of Isaac Clark in video games but first
a brief word from today's sponsor this
video is sponsored by factor factor
makes meeting your nutritional goals
easier than ever by delivering fresh
never Frozen dietitian approved meals
right to your doorstep feel up fast this
year with factors ready to eat
nutritious meals delivered straight to
your door leaving you time and energy to
tackle everything on your to-do list
personally I really enjoyed the jalapeno
lime cheddar chicken and my wife said
she loved the chorizo chili meal plus
the mango fruit juice tasted pretty good
without making me feel guilty for
drinking it like I always do when I have
a soda our whole dinner was cooked in
just four minutes and it tasted
fantastic with 34 Chef prepared
dietitian approved weekly options
there's always something new to try plus
you can round out your meals and
replenish your snack Supply with an
assortment of 36 plus sweets smoothies
juices and more satisfying add-ons head
to factor75.com or click the link below
and use Godzilla Mendoza 15 to get 50
off your first Factor box again that's
Godzilla Mendoza 50 to get 50 off your
first Factor box at factor75.com now
back to the video
no
I think this is probably the most well
documented Isaac appearance and probably
because just visually the funniest if
you load up Skate 3 from 2010 and head
over to the cheat code menu and type in
Dead Space 2 Isaac's very same model
from Dead Space 1 is loaded in as a
skater you can play as complete with his
own rig themed skateboard now Isaac can
grind rails do backflips hang out with
actor Jason Lee and wipe the hell out
because I'm not very good at this game
yeah I haven't really played any skating
games since Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 3 so
I'm a little bit behind the curve on
this I played the tutorial again mostly
just to listen to Jason Lee and I'm
still struggling a bit to do anything
that looks serviceably cool however this
game does allow you to just like Chuck
your skateboard and run around awkwardly
flailing your arms and jumping up and
down it's nice to see Isaac doing
something so relaxing and harmless plus
you can call your board back from across
the map like mjolnir I guess he used
Kinesis on it maybe his skating prowess
wouldn't be the best in this suit but I
can guarantee that he's safe during any
major face plants into the concrete it's
like being covered in bubble wrap it's a
impossible to skin his knee on the
sidewalk not for lack of trying
[Applause]
here's some footage of someone else
being good at the game that I found on
Twitter to offset my lack of extreme
so this video would have been a lot
faster and easier to edit had I made it
a point to just use someone else's
footage for everything but for whatever
reason I have a natural aversion to easy
and fast video production and decided to
get all this footage myself or I have my
pal Angus get whatever I personally
couldn't using his totally unmodified
PS3 with no aftermarket alterations
applied at all
I paid for the rest of these though
invest in physical Media Kids everything
will be delisted except your discs some
of these skins and DLCs are no longer
accessible in any legitimate way because
they've been delisted from digital
stores or they were only available in
specific regions so Angus really helped
me out by getting some of the trickier
ones nailed down thanks man
something about seeing Isaac and Hell
fighting demons with a scythe made of a
spinal column oddly doesn't look that
jarring sure his suit is futuristic but
it also feels very Gothic too I think
that really speaks to the uniqueness of
the art design in the original dead
space I could line up spaceships and
power armor from many different
franchises that would all look
relatively similar but you'd always be
able to pick out the ones from Dead
Space maybe because they're key design
philosophy is covering everything in red
games on this list this is the one I'm
really bummed out I had to let Angus
record instead because getting this
costume is a whole process
Isaac's suit is only available in the UK
version of the game called Dante's
Inferno death Edition and it's from a
code that comes in the game box which
means I'd have to find a copy of the
game that's been unopened for over a
decade which is incredibly expensive at
this point or find a copy of the code
that hasn't been redeemed yet somehow
naturally we just had to go to some
alternate methods
I've never played this game before but
it looks awesome part of me really
misses this era of spectacle fighter
games where everyone was trying to be
Kratos or Dante
uh different Dante this game is so early
2010s it's got a lot of blood and gore
and a lot of casual female nudity and
from the looks of it some pretty
Kick-Ass combat I can only show so much
but I will say it's pretty cool that the
Isaac's skin works during in-game
cutscenes as well look he's just
chilling next to this naked ghost lady I
guess
some of the worst putting I have ever
seen
man Angus got to play Dante's Inferno
and I had to record this I've played
golf in real life and it's all right but
God I just can't imagine genuinely
having fun playing a video game version
of it you don't even get to walk around
outside and breathe in fresh air and hit
stuff with a metal stick
I didn't even want to try this game so I
just let my mom play it because she has
a decent understanding of golf and
played some of the PS2 entries in this
series
she wasn't very good at it at first but
with time and a few drinks her skill
improved
some of they all swing oil to help her
game
the requirements to unlock him here to
buy him in the Pro Shop for like 20 000
tiger bucks and complete the first
Boston challenge but getting to that
challenge requires playing for a long
long time and this game is boring as
while watching professional golf
of every game on our list this one was
the single hardest one to unlock Isaac
in without just cheating but there's no
way to cheat because all the codes for
this game have gone completely
undiscovered even after 14 years you
have to play for hours and hours and
hours through these mind-numbingly hard
challenges for only one to three measly
points at a time until you have 45 to
even attempt the Boston challenge this
one took us several days of work and
frustration to get this footage I truly
despise this game and it's made me
thoroughly sure I will never play
another golf game again in my life I
would have just bought the costume with
real life money to save time but this
game's been delisted and so has every
piece of DLC that goes with it so this
is the only way if I could run up behind
Luke Donald and smack him in the back of
the leg with a nine iron to skip these
damn challenges if I could have just
taken someone else's footage I would but
this is the only other video of this
thing on the entire damn internet
in fact I might just be the only person
in the world to have HD footage of this
because this costume's obscurity makes
it border on Lost media I challenge you
to look all the other footage of it
online has been deleted from the EA
website it used to be on
oh
this is probably all that's left so good
news media preserved I hate the concept
of games being de-listed or even bonus
content becoming impossible to access
with time
everything should still be playable
after time has passed and if not just
letting people be able to see it is the
next best thing
I'm happy to Archive this if no one else
has but still
this ended up taking like 60 hours to
unlock it was a second job for my family
all of us just sitting around the TV
watching my mom for five hours a day
after work just trying her best to make
these butts and land on the greens
we even invited my uncle over to help
with a few challenges until 4am one day
since he's pretty good at these games
and after over a week of struggling we
finally crossed the finish line that was
the most satisfying and exciting
conclusion to a [__] golf game that
I've ever been part of I should have
recorded the audio of the entire family
sitting around the TV high-fiving
cheering and on the verge of tears when
we finally got him hold on a second Roxy
this is not Tiger Woods so you may be
wondering why this game why is he here
is it because him and Tiger Woods both
share a history of running and fright
from their blonde ex while reeling with
guilt nah it's because all these early
games on our list Tiger Woods Dante's
Inferno and Skate 3 are all built on the
same engine as the original Dead Space
porting his model over to these other
games was exceptionally easy because he
was already rigged to the animations and
they figured why the hell not throw them
in there
it's like as easy as dragging and
dropping a file they weren't putting him
in all these games because they wanted
to put him forth as a new company mascot
or something it was more just an inside
joke that just kept evolving and
eventually got way out of control
really know anything about Dragon Age
other than it has some Mass Effect
Easter eggs I've never really paid
attention to this series because I like
sci-fi stuff way more than fantasy stuff
but for some reason I'm pretty sure I
got this mixed up with The Witcher or
something because I did not expect the
gameplay to look like this
kind of like a Marvel Ultimate Alliance
Dungeon Crawler sort of thing that's
neat I guess but unlocking Isaac was a
lot easier back in the day originally
you could just get him if you had a Dead
Space 2 save file on the same platform
and voila a suit of armor styled after
the Dead Space 2 Advanced suit
however they suspended that
functionality for a few years then they
changed it so you can get free with the
game on Origin I don't have a good
gaming PC so I just bought this game for
Angus I guess so he could do it it's
kind of ironic that the two games with
Isaac in a fantasy setting are the ones
that are such a pain in the ass to get a
playable copy with I really like that
they created an Isaac costume that
definitely still fits this game's
aesthetic instead of just plopping in
that crazy blue and white Iron Man suit
this looks recognizable as Isaac but
still works as a dragon fighting
nightman
I assume they fight dragons again I I
don't really know
the lights on his helmet and his back
work that's cool
you speak of the Dead return to life not
life Necromorphs are Abominations
this one's three costumes have you ever
wanted to see Isaac curb stomp small
furry Woodland creatures that are now
long forgotten PlayStation mascots then
PlayStation All-Stars is the Smash Bros
clone for you
this game is Just kind of adorable you
know that they thought that they could
compete with smash using this roster
Isaac isn't even a PlayStation exclusive
character they just grabbed whoever
Nintendo wasn't gonna use History's
Greatest musician
I would not speak of this now keep in
mind I don't play Smash Bros because I
have a job and a wife and friends so I'm
not totally Adept at most of these look
at all the IPS we own platform Fighters
out here but I think I started to get
the hang of this one I did play the
tutorial to try and get the basics down
and I realize this game is actually
pretty fun I really like how Isaac's
moveset in this game incorporates a lot
of his weapons and tools from the dead
space series he can use stasis the
Ripper contact beam plasma cutter
Kinesis proximity mine and probably
others if you can see that microscopic
character working his ass off while a
million other things happen on the
screen and particle effects shoot out of
your eyeballs but sometimes the action
gets real close and personal so you can
really see the hatred when Isaac kicks
fat Princess right in the face while
she's down or telekinetically strangles
PaRappa the Rapper these character
pairings are just crazy like look it's
Isaac during that time where they
redesigned him to look more like Nathan
Drake and everyone complains so they
changed it back alongside Cole from
Infamous during that time where they
redesigned him to look more like Nathan
Drake and everyone complains they
changed it back and Dante from DMC
during that time where they redesigned
him to look more like Nathan Drake and
everyone complained so they changed it
back and also Nathan Drake
getting white guys in video games the
other neat thing is that this game
features fully voice acted cutscenes for
each character you play ranging from
these simple slideshow Graphics
featuring Ellie langford's terrible
push-up bra redesign from the game that
had a love triangle subplot I know you
two had a thing but she's mine now and I
love her too much to let her do this to
these in-game interactions where your
character meets their rival and they
have a little back and forth with some
other random PlayStation brand and crazy
person the Zeus is loose there's a bit
of an unfair power differential at play
here given that one of these characters
is a competent albeit normal human man
in a 60 pound suit of armor defending
himself with repurposed mining equipment
and the other is in ancient deity that
can grow to the size of a skyscraper and
shoot lightning out of his enlarged
pores like a sweaty Pikachu with
glandular issues
I guess technically Isaac has indeed
fought and killed much larger foes but I
don't want to talk about that regardless
Isaac still uses Kinesis to just flat
out catch lightning and I think that
asserts just how fully this era of the
character jumped the shark
behind you
so I guess there was a period of time
where the sims series tried to appeal to
younger audiences with more cutesy Chibi
characters to compete with Nintendo's
usage of customizable knees and Wii
games the result was this series of
games called My Sims that started on
Nintendo consoles it had a handful of
spin-offs like my Sims party my Sims
racing My Sims Kingdom my Sims earthrise
and these two while Isaac was slated to
be part of Agents he was eventually cut
out for reasons unknown but he did make
it into Sky Heroes along with Commander
Shepard Sky Heroes is the airplane
dogfight game where you're cute and
cuddly Sim uses a biplane to harmlessly
explode their enemies while shouting
indecipherable cluttered syllables with
no discernible pattern
it's like if Snoopy and the Red Baron
were
actually it's a lot like Snoopy in the
Red Baron oh good job you found ticker
why don't they speak simlish in the
cinematic trailer for this character
Isaac doesn't get a unique plane but
it's just funny seeing him portrayed so
harmless and adorable considering the
source material he's a depressed 40 year
old man with extreme schizophrenia that
uses a magnetic floating circular saw to
cut through hordes of possessed child
Corpses
put them in Three Little Big Planet
games
the great victory for health and safety
but a thrilling ride nonetheless for the
affordable price of like a buck 99 Dead
Space Two eyes it can be a playable skin
in The Adventures of Sackboy and as
various textures of sack this is a side
scroller sandbox game that lets you
design levels and puzzles and whatnot I
actually saw someone recreate multiple
levels from Dead Space itself in this
game because the options have so much
depth what's especially cool about this
DLC is that if you bought it on the PS3
for a Little Big Planet 2 it's shared
with all of the following games in the
series so you have the Isaac costume and
Little Big Planet Mario Kart competitor
and eventually can even transfer over to
LittleBigPlanet 3 which is on PS4 and
can also be played with backwards
compatibility on PS5
so like a DLC character you bought back
in 2011 can still be played with later
consoles today
why this isn't the norm for things like
this is beyond me I think everything you
buy should just carry over on the
account so you don't have to worry about
losing access to it when something dumb
happens
like the PS3 or Xbox 360 store is going
offline which is going to happen soon
makes producing videos like this one
infinitely more nerve-wracking to pull
together
[Applause]
high five
in the lane he's on fire
this game has been de-listed on every
platform is not available on disk
probably because it was too much wacky
b-ball Insanity for people to handle
Isaac plays basketball all the time
actually that's that's Canon I have a
great jump shot
just appreciate this image for a second
from a completely unmodified official
game release even its history with guest
characters such as the Mortal Kombat
fellas and the Clinton Administration
it's not shocking that NBA Jam has some
silly additional characters in it this
one includes three different skins from
Dead Space 2. the security armor
Advanced suit and the Vintage suit it's
kind of whack not to have his iconic
baby back ribs platter shoulder suit
included but the Vintage one looks close
enough this is another one where you
have to unlock these costumes by just
playing a ton of the game but it's not
nearly as bad as Tiger Woods was he
could get it in like an hour and a half
maybe less if you're better at the game
and also unlike PGA Tour the fun of this
game is not from its realistic
simulation of sports
it's fun because it's unrealistic
basketball the goal is just to do really
crazy dunks from across the tiny Port
this game's got a really simple arcadey
pick up and play sort of feel so it's
very accessible and that seems more like
my type of thing since I don't play
sports simulators much sometimes you
just want to sit back relax and watch
people on fire playing four-person
basketball
foreign
[Music]
consoles would you believe he's on the
PSP edition of Army of Two the 40th Day
not in the main game just the PSP
version getting footage of this one was
complicated to say the least Angus and I
found out some guy by the name of red
flame Fox on YouTube did have some
footage of this from an emulation of the
game but we didn't want to just steal
that so Angus ran his own emulation and
then found out Isaac is only unlockable
if you have a completed save file with
all the good guy choices because this
was from that Infamous slash web of
Shadows era where video games would stop
you at a cutscene and ask if you wanted
to save a cat from a tree or eat a baby
and then the following level just
wouldn't care or acknowledge whichever
choice you made because that would be
too hard to program turns out
downloading a 100 save file for this
game online included a path where the
player made a combination of good and
bad choices which locked us out of the
costume so Angus actually contacted red
flame Fox and asked for his save file to
get the costume for our own unique
footage special thanks to Flame for
helping us out his channel is linked
below and hopefully by the time this
video is up the save file will now be
made public and Linked In the
description too so you can also play as
Isaac in this game the other unlockable
character was Dante from Dante's Inferno
but we couldn't get footage of both at
the same time because the NPC player
always defaults to being a normal outfit
outstanding
I have to put it out there this is a
fine example of a professionally made
lower poly version of the level 3 suit
from Dead Space for any of you Maniacs
in the modding Community out there now
is your chance to rip this and try to
put it in some PS2 era games it's got
the right look that it wouldn't be out
of place in like Half-Life or even
combat evolve now that that's on PC I'm
just saying we can dramatically increase
the amount of games Isaac is in with
these resources not that the amount of
games he's in already is small by any
definition but even games pre-2008 are
now on the table if one of you is crazy
enough to try it you know I'm nothing if
not thorough so let's blast through some
of the other smaller or weirder ones I'm
having fun with this topic Minecraft
Xbox 360 Edition released an official
Isaac Clarke scan in skin pack 5 way
back in 2013 or something and I remember
I actually had it so I dusted off the
console hooked it up and got some
footage and I realized it's a stupid
Dead Space 3 snowsuit design that'll
never be as cool as the other ones so I
decided to build something in this game
for the first time since I was like 15.
it was a surreal experience coming back
to Minecraft after all these years I
hadn't played it since my save file
corrupted in the giant City I spent like
four years working on was lost forever I
was just so sad about it that I never
wanted to play it again for the rest of
my teenage years but picking it back up
was like riding a bike granted there's
like 50 new types of blocks in the game
that I don't recognize but I knew I
could eyeball the materials enough to
build a big classic Isaac statue
that's nice that made me feel good and
since we're getting really nostalgic I
kept asking my parents to buy me those
damn Microsoft points cards for this
useless [__] Isaac from Dead Space one
two and three had various skins you
could customize your Xbox avatar with
remember these yeah you're tearing up a
little I can see it they had little
emotes and everything it's just a shame
you couldn't do anything with these I
mean you could load them up in some Xbox
Live arcade games so technically Isaac
is available on all of those too yeah
let's play some Doritos Crash Course
this has gone so [__] off the rails
okay this one was actually impossible to
get our own gameplay from but I
definitely did play Playstation home
back when it was a thing here's the
point where we're getting my own footage
of this stuff is becoming a logistical
nightmare so shout out to the people who
uploaded these next three entries I'll
link you in the description PlayStation
Home was like a toned down realistic
Sims game that ran on PlayStation and
was full of purchasable items like
furniture for your virtual apartment and
costumes for your character to wear it
also had a massive Hub area where
players could gather around and
socialize with in-game chat emotes while
surrounded by Massive Billboards and TV
screens displaying whatever new
PlayStation crap was big at the moment
it was like a heavily monetized and
commercialized progenitor that sort of
experience offered by like VR chat these
days
you and your buds could just dress up as
licensed characters and chill in an
imaginary Video Game Bar it even had
entire levels themed after specific
games so you could hang out in areas
resembling iconic gaming locations just
without all the NPCs trying to fight you
Isaac's costumes from the first and
second Dead Space were something you
could buy from the in-game store and I
distinctly remember them looking like
they too were just models ported
straight over from dead space and fitted
to the new animations they also offered
a version with slightly different body
proportions for female player models
which is neat too look you could pretend
it's Vandal from the mobile game I had a
good time wearing the level 3 suit and
exploring through the Star Wars Cantina
levels or the Assassin's Creed lab place
however this game was eventually
shuttered in 2015 by Sony and was no
longer playable
until in 2021 some massively dedicated
fans of PlayStation Home brought it back
online through mods some insanely
intricate tweaking and restoring of any
cache data and a lot of altered PS3s so
if you go digging hard enough you can
actually go find a way to play this game
again now that it's been restored under
the name destination home nearly all of
the footage you're viewing has been from
destination home provided by the team
just for this very video so that's
another exclusive I got in contact with
figment the community manager on their
Twitter and the Gang pulled together to
record this on the off chance you have a
PS3 where you never uninstalled PS home
you can also get in contact with them
and donate that data to help them
preserve even more of the game for
future generations to play
so why the hell isn't this guy in the
helmet ever talk
Battlefield Hardline is made by the same
devs as the original Dead Space Trilogy
so they put in a bunch of Dead Space
Easter eggs like a criminal mafia guy
playing the game in one level and you
can find Isaac's helmet in a store
there's a billion of these Easter eggs
in here you could tell that they were
nostalgic for the good old days while
they were forced to work in the
battlefield mines under EA's company
mandated try to beat Call of Duty sales
work order and Duke Nukem Forever you
can find a corpse in one of the alien
levels that has Isaac's helmet kinda
that's one Dead Space Marine haha that's
funny this game sucks The Simpsons game
this game came out the year before dead
space but this poster is still pretty
funny now you kind of know how to draw
Isaac in The Simpsons art style if
that's some like fan art thing you want
to do
fix the helmet oh my God
Angus downloaded this whole game just to
stand next to this poster for a second
[Music]
it's become oddly customary that these
types of videos somehow always end with
a fortnight skin I'm just glad that Dead
Space crossovers are still happening and
the tradition lives on
granted a fortnight skin is the easiest
one to do these days because every
character has one but I love it in the
remake version of the level 3 engineer
suit he comes with a plasma cutter
pickaxe so like if he took two of the
laser pointers off and put big knives on
it for whatever reason he has a rigged
backpack that changes color when you
take damage
personally I would have liked it to
actually mimic the level of Health your
character has like it does in the real
game but maybe that was too much
programming for a single DLC skin
his other thing is a tiny ishimura which
is like yeah whatever no one's using
that it probably should have been a tiny
marker since Isaac does have a history
of hauling those things around from
place to place for story purposes I just
wish he had one emote that involved more
stomping because I had to sub in a few
other ones instead it just looks right
you know
okay now you die
[Applause]
thank God for that Dead Space remake
giving the franchise a Fighting Chance
at continuing it really reminded
everyone why we like the first game so
much in the first place and it really
shined a light on what Dead Space 3 was
lacking so the future looks ironically
bright for such a dystopian story I have
a feeling Dead Space is going to keep
stomping for a long time and with that
even more crossovers Easter eggs and
references to Isaac or potentially some
other helmeted protagonist in new games
in a weird way he's sort of a sleeper
icon in the world of gaming considering
his prevalence and recognizability those
three horizontal slatted lines in his
helmet are just really iconic and like
instantly recognizable compared to so
many other Space Marine looking dudes I
think he's earned a spot up there with
some of the all-time greats if only
because he has such a sick costume alone
but on top of that I just really love
the character of this every man schlub
becoming the focal point of some Cosmic
horror beyond our comprehension Isaac's
original model in particular has been
ported to so many different places hell
it's even been ported to the Remake I'm
certain this is the old character model
because you can see the corners on parts
that are meant to be rounded and the
lower poly sort of look to some edges on
the helmet they re-textured it maybe to
look a little less out of place but I
know that old gorgeous set of armor when
I see it so given just how many games
it's appeared in I think we should
discuss the very real likelihood that
this character model of the level 3 suit
may be the most reused video game asset
in gaming history
either that or I'll find out some random
chair model was ported across every
single Call of Duty game and technically
edges It Out by three entries or
something but Isaac here is a real
Contender for that frankly I love just
how many games he's appeared in and I
hope that Trend continues forever I want
him to just keep popping up in random
games for the fun of it and I'll
probably keep buying them just for that
character skin like an idiot and hey
he's silly game mod people that can put
Lego Spider-Man into the Insomniac game
why not throw the sad engineer man into
even funnier places let's see the
strangest game you can make him a
playable character in send the clips to
me on Twitter let's make a game out of
this
one day it'll just be in every game
except probably Dead Space 4.
I always get mad at YouTube for not
putting my videos in the subscription
box because people will comment finally
Xavier uploads again after all these
years not knowing three other videos
came out within the last month already
so maybe that stupid Bell icon thing
will help you remember I exist if you
want other ways to support the channel
you can always go hit up that patreon
for early videos and exclusive stuff
because it's just a dollar I'm not
kidding it's only one dollar Isn't that
cool if everyone who watched this video
donated one dollar a month I'd be able
to afford a house for myself so that
would be that would be really cool you
can also check out our merch on T public
or just buy some of my random stuff on
eBay I have a pretty substantial
collection of old toys that are still in
the box in perfect condition so go take
a look in case you find something you
like and lastly since this is a YouTube
video and you probably play fortnite
drop my Creator quote Xavier GM next
time you buy a silly dancer cool
character skin really helps me out
see you next time
[Music]
foreign